[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today up next
we have Kevin in Huntington West
Virginia Hey Kevin welcome to the show
hi hello how can we help um okay I have
I'm not very familiar with your all's um
stuff I I've kind of just started
watching um some of your highlights and
stuff on YouTube recently um but enough
to get an idea a basic idea of like the
de snowball stuff um and I've gotten
myself into a little bit of a bond like
I'm not I'm not drowning yet okay but I
kind of see that if I keep going the way
I'm going I've kind of just been jumping
from crisis to crisis and juggling y
everything and making it work for a
while yeah I kind of see that if I stay
on that path that um I'm going to be
drowning before too long okay so Kevin
we're up against the clock a little bit
so I want to make sure we get to your um
to your question and situation so um how
much yeah how much debt do you have um I
have uh 63,000 total okay um 40 40 47 of
it is between cars um 2900 of it is uh
credit Consumer Debt okay um I have
9,000 uh student loans and uh 3,800 in
collections
okay um some of that some of the credit
some of the Consumer Debt is like uh
like Rent A Center kind of stuff like
weekly payments y um and my question is
th those aren't necessarily the
smallest you know Kevin I'm gonna hold
I'm gonna keep you on hold for a second
we're heading into a break a hard clock
so if you'll hold on to the hold on the
line okay so as we were talking you were
saying some of your consumer debts I
think of the 2900 that was credit cards
is also you were saying was it uh
furniture from Rena Center
yeah yeah like stuff like that like a
bed I um I had to buy tires for my truck
and I I financed it weekly pay um kind
of stuff how much of it is
that uh about
$3,000 okay and what is what is that
amount to
monthly um well it's it's weekly pay
okay we each one of those comes out
weekly um the the cheapest one is $21 a
week the other one's $30 a week the
other one's $74 a week can you give it
what happens when you give back the rent
Center stuff like what happens if you're
like I don't want to rent it
anymore um nothing they they just get it
back so the payment's the payment you
can't go you can't say I don't want to
rent it and and get out of it no yeah
yeah no I I can take it back and I just
don't have that stuff anymore so the
tires I couldn't I would have the
payment anymore okay I would go through
and go what can I give back like
obviously you need tires on your car but
is there a way that we
can save up some quick cash and get you
the tires you need and get cuz I want
you to get out of that as quickly as
possible because the interest on that
I'm sure is not great no it's not and
that that was my
question because I I've recently got my
a side hustle um I got a job basically
to do nothing I'm on call for a recer
service where if I get a call I have to
go out and work but it's overnight and I
usually don't get called and it's $300 a
week um and I can get out from under
like the one is $26 so I could pay it
off the check and that I'm off from I'm
out from under that one and that frees
up 2132 to roll into another thing with
the debt snowball yeah I for me things
like Rena Center that's akin to like
payday loans and stuff it's really just
scraping the bottom of the barrel so I'd
want you to get that stuff clean and
honestly like I said I'd be looking and
going what can I just give back and if
you're making $300 doing this wrecking
service how quickly can you save up what
you need for tires Baseline you know
what I mean and just get yourself back
on your feet in that way and then you've
also got this dead in collections and so
the way you listed it out you know 47 or
$47,000 in cars 29,000 in credit I want
you to go through even further with a
fine tooth comb and really list each
debt in order from smallest to largest
because that's going to give you not
only a clearer picture of truly what's
going on but it's going to break it in a
way that you can like you just said hey
this one is for you know $2,000 I can I
can tackle that and it's going to help
you see it in its smallest form so that
you know okay like what is it going to
take how many hours do I need to do okay
I can pay that one off and you're just
going one by one line by line um yeah
for the cars Kevin how much you said
47,000 for cars so how much is each
car um for my truck it's $700 a month uh
or what's like the total loan sorry no
22,000 22 for your truck okay what's the
next car yep uh my wife's SUV it's 243
24,000 okay and then 2,900 on credit
cards yes that's including the the
rental centers the that's right you were
saying that okay yeah so yeah if you'll
break those out per credit card per
Renta Center 7 700 on one 300 on another
um 1,000 for uh a bed 500 for my tires
and $200
um for a computer okay um then like if I
paid off the computer with the check
that I get today y yep that's exactly
right and then and $99,000 in student
loans is that right yes okay and then
some in
collections 300 what's your income like
you and your wife's combined income uh
combined are take comes of uh just over
100,000 that's a take-home okay good so
$63,000 in debt 100,000 take-home you
know there's a part to this where I go
okay what would happen if you guys lived
on
$60,000 and you're going through this
you've got 40,000 just in your money
that you can put towards this every year
plus 300 a week side Hustle the side
hustle and your wife getting a side
hustle when you look at it like that you
realize Kevin that this can you can
knock this out fairly quickly 18 to 24
months right well that and yeah and like
that was why I called because like the
de snowball it it I think it's the list
smallest to largest right that's right
exactly take on the and like some of
these weekly payments aren't smallest
but if I attacked the weekly payments
first and got them paid off really quick
that has me paying like $2,500 a week
towards the ne uh uh $2,500 a month
towards the next well the smallest to
largest is not the payment size it's the
size of the debt the total debt oh okay
so you look at like if you like you said
with those Rena centers I think you said
one one of the total debts was 200 one
of the total debts was 300 right yeah so
those would be my small I was thinking
payments nope by by the balance by theal
and you want to stay current on
everything so you'll stay current on all
the payments pay off that smallest and
then Kevin you guys you know you and
your wife because you know I mean even
just this picture of the debt this isn't
to shame or embarrass you but you know
it's a picture of like this is normal
like you guys were just kind of doing
what you wanted and you make great money
and you're we feeling like how are we
broke like how do we feel like we have
no money and we have to go to Renta
Center for our furniture when we make
$100,000 a year combin like this
shouldn't like yeah this is not how it
should be and so as you guys start this
process Kevin I would really encourage
you to lean in when you start to feel
these wins because I would bet you Kevin
that you make you guys may look up at
the $24,000 SUV and be like man could we
sell it for 26,000 get 2K and get a
crappy car for a little bit and and
knock this out even sooner cuz there's a
taste of Freedom Kevin that you guys
have never had have never experienced
and for you and your wife doing this
process together it is huge it's huge so
I want you to stay on the line because
we want to give you Financial Peace
University for you and your wife to go
through together and you guys it's our
seven it's our nine lesson course and
you guys walk through that and every
dollar premium and this is our budgeting
app that connects to your bank and it's
really going to help you guys list out
very specifically hey here's our
paycheck where is it all going this is
going to give you a road map to get this
stuff paid off and I think yeah with the
side hustle and everything Kevin this is
it I mean yeah your question was what's
the best use of our months I bet yeah
our side hustle money and it's to yep
throw at that smallest debt amount and
as you guys start to really make this
traction and this progress you're going
to feel it and it's going to be it's
going to be amazing and we're here for
you so keep keep watching the show and
listening for that encouragement because
the way you're going to view money is
totally different than how you've lived
and it's going to feel uncomfortable at
times it's not going to always be fun
during the season of sacrifice but the
more you guys sacrifice and really
buckle down yeah the traction you're
going to see is amazing look and you you
hit the nail on the head you know
$100,000 you think all right we're we're
doing well like the average family is
somewhere around 67,000 so if you are
above that Mark kind of status tells us
hey that's good you're doing well and it
does feel weird when you're like wait a
minute I'm buying my furniture at Rena
Center like I told I can't buy tires I
can't buy tires and you know I told you
during the break I I I knew this couple
they were older than us but when I was
in college I went to their house and I
remember them saying like our furniture
is from Rena Center and they had two
giant SUVs that were brand new and I
remember thinking wow they've made it
but they their situation was probably
very similar to what we just heard and
I've said this before and I'll say it
again when you start to make these
changes it will show so if you try to do
this in a vacuum or in the quiet like
you have to just accept hey if I really
want to do this and I want to do it
faster I might drive a different car
like people might see me going from
driving a 2023 Infinity down to you know
a 2015 Camry and they may ask me
questions about that and that is okay
number one it's none of their business
unless you want it to be their business
but if they ask you there's no shame in
saying you know what we were out of
control and we're getting our life back
yep like let's normalize that as the
status symbol of Amen I'm getting my
life back and I am being a responsible
adult and when you give back that bed to
Rena Center and give back you know the
tires to Rena center that is you being a
responsible adult create your free every
dollar budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life